[Music]
all right on to the game of the hour it
would seem we have a lot of embargo
heuristic restrictions yeah man I am
tripping out today I played Zelda until
like 2:00 a.m. last night that was my
that was the most time I've had with a
switch - we're gonna get into the switch
specifically at the end of the show
today we wanted to vote a lot of time -
Zelda kind of based around the idea of
whether it feels like a Zelda game
because from what we've been talking
about and I know like what you know like
we're right next to giant bomb we've
been talking to them about it - and Kali
you're a Zelda fan yes to say the least
Pete you are - so am i and a lot of the
things that we're all sitting around the
office is that we're excited for this
game for reasons other than we usually
are for a Zelda game sure yeah based on
what we've seen what we played it's
frankly it's the unexpected yeah it's
it's the discovery of things you never
saw coming and never realized or
possible in the game and all that exists
around you know what appears to be a
traditional a Zelda game so in my mind
it kind of feels at the best of both
worlds
yeah and to clarify for people watching
if you have questions in YouTube chat
and twitch at GameSpot send them our way
I have a few written down but I have a
few things on Twitter Pete your review
will be up can you talk about when it'll
be up yeah 3 a.m. Pacific time tomorrow
morning ok so it's coming in hot yeah
early early review based on swimming
like Japan times something like that who
knows yeah so 3 a.m. Pacific tomorrow
you can see the full review Pete's
pretty much done with it for the most
part you gotta edit it and whatnot oh
with the review yeah yeah it's yeah
right been cramming on the review
there's a lot to unpack in this game and
we can technically right now only speak
about the first 5 at 5 hours but even
then there's more to talk about this
game than yeah host games yeah I mean
that was my experience even playing
demos at e3 and stuff and playing a demo
more recently as everybody did a
different thing and everyone I talked to
you it was like oh I went over here and
I saw this and there was this cute thing
that happened when I cooked and like
ling-ling comes when he cooks and it's
like the one thing I took away from the
demo I thought it was I just loved the
little details right and then everyone I
talked to you was like oh
I went to a mountain and you can freeze
like you get really cold and I'm like I
didn't even know there was a mountain I
could go to in this demo like it even
even in like a 15 minute demo you have
all of that done back after almost a
week playing this game almost non-stop
Mike in playing it last night first a
couple hours discovered 20 minutes first
20 minutes discovered something I had
never seen before can we talk about that
or no yeah okay um that's the thing
about this game I mean aside from the
survival elements aside from just how
enticing it is to explore I know when
the first Zelda ever came out that was
like the first time people were holy
[ __ ] I want to explore every inch of
this and then ocarina came out showed
you could do it in 3d you know from the
first five hours that we're talking
about to me it felt like I looked out
over this world this shot right here
that we're looking at it's just like
that's a promise on this game's parts
like you're gonna [ __ ] like it
wrapped up in all of this and it does
feel a little bit like a Zelda game and
some of the mechanics and you know
obviously the aesthetic and the charm
and the music and a lot of what the
story that's unraveling that I and just
getting into P you have seen much much
more than I have but yeah we were
finding things continually we're having
these emergent situation or having these
water cooler conversations that we
haven't really had since like Metal Gear
Solid 5 but even not to that exert
passes that and that getting that game
was filled with creative opportunities
yes right but those were always at your
hand it was sort of like how you had
control over the elements at play and
what you decided to come up with this is
almost just about seeing things happen
because of what an enemy is doing or
something that you just never considered
before cuz the game doesn't tell you
yeah yeah much at all it's basically
like alright you have to go save the
princess you it tells you calamity Ganon
is taking away me Hansen go to these
things to get a couple powers and asleep
for a hundred years this we four hundred
years go to these shrines get these
powers and then basically like alright
man you got to go like go go and you
know like the one of the first combat
situations I got into it was you know
the thing we saw at e3 right where it's
like a skull looking like cave there's
some goblins inside of there
and I go up there with you know I found
something better than a tree branch but
it's still just like a basic Club and I
roll up there and I'm trying to like
sneak and like I killed the guy in the
platform and he's got a bow and arrow
and so I tried to use that but by the
time I've got that there's other goblins
that kill me it took the first combat
encounter the first real one took me
like three or four time tries to solve
yeah and it was because I had to find a
bow and arrow and shoot a rope to drop
an explosive thing to blow up the
barrels of the guys inside the cave and
it's just all these little like
intricate things that you have to like
take care of and consider because if you
don't you're gonna get your ass handed
to you yeah it's very easy to die in
this game both in combat and if you push
yourself too far yeah I to go back to
what we're talking about I was playing
for about 20 minutes and I got a shield
and I had a bow you kind of just stumble
across these things it you know it to
clarify it's not just you don't get the
fairy bow it's not the Kokiri bow you
get a bow and you're gonna get like 10
more in the next 20 every single weapon
you get you get from killing an enemy or
finding it in the field
you're not going to shops and purchasing
weapons that's nothing yeah look that's
crazy yeah you're you're getting these
abilities with that chica slate that
thing that's hanging on his neck around
his belt it's kinda like the focus from
horizon zero dawn now that I think of it
the way it's framed narrative Lee but
that's neither here nor there yeah I had
a bow I didn't have any arrows I went up
to this bow cobbling camp I was holding
my shield up a guy was pointing bow and
arrow at me I was like ah [ __ ] he's
about to hit me and he shot me and the
arrows stuck in my shield is like oh
that's cool um I didn't have any arrows
left so I kind of like I just retreated
cuz there's four other guys I don't
wanna fight them because this game is
pretty tough and pretty unforgiving so I
went to you know like not holster but
put my shield back on my back like
unequip it to run away and I was like oh
I wish that it would have shown the
arrow still in the shield and it
disappeared I was like Dan that sucks
but then I was like oh holy [ __ ] it just
added that arrow that was stuck in my
shield to my inventory so I had I was
talking to Pete and Rob and apparently
they'd even know that and I've been
playing 20 minutes and like we're still
seeing things that the other how many
hours have you put into it now can you
talk about at that I don't know if I can
I can't remember but you put a lot
playing it for almost a week almost
non-stop and you didn't see that or
maybe you didn't notice it that's the
thing there's so much [ __ ] going on this
world you're always thinking it's so
it's do
the cult but I think that works right
cuz in old games you're I was just
talking to these NPCs and Zelda for the
sake of it right I was just saying I
want to know more about this world but
here they tell you useful stuff yeah
like this guy has an item that you
eventually want to trade to him for or
this person I had this really cool
moment yesterday but before I was
leaving the office where Matt and Jimmy
who were both playing it to Jimmy must
have any conversation with this person
and I'm not gonna get the specifics
because I won't spoil it I don't even
know if I can't talk about that
specifically but Jimmy had this
conversation this person they had this
proposal for him and he said yeah it
turned out he shouldn't have but then
Matt knew not to say that to this person
because he had spoken to this random NPC
in Kakariko village which is nuts
that's what like I don't know if it
affected the outcome but like they both
had these completely different
experiences within those you have to do
the merchant know oh it's like this clan
I was talking to right yeah and they
were talking about he's like oh holy
[ __ ] that person told you that says yeah
that that's it was it was a water-cooler
conversation where they were discovering
that they both had completely different
experiences it's like like when you were
in school and you would have like a
playground conversation about like I
don't know how to beat this boss how do
I do it like talking to your friends
like when you know ocarina came out and
would be like oh I you can go here and
how do I do this and like it's it's a
total and now we're seeing snowboarding
yeah crazy but the the thing I love
about it is I haven't had that in a long
time a lot of times I can just kind of
figure out a game I don't necessarily
need to ask the people I know for like
oh how do I do this what's the best way
to do this and then this one is like I
could talk about this for I feel like
months I feel like I'm gonna I'm gonna
be playing this for months and never see
everything people will be flooding
Reddit and yoga for years to come like
with stuff from this game this is Rob
Handler he's footage of snowboarding
down a mountain on a shield kind of
Legolas Inge and then you see this kills
these three and he could have dropped a
bomb here from the paraglider right yeah
but he chose to do something way cooler
oh he's about to do it here actually
yeah cuz you've seen a ton I was
watching you play like a very very late
game stuff and there's crazy watching
hoping yeah there you go so you could
drop the remote bombs and see you get
you're like a [ __ ] bomber plane oh my
god but then the thing took the thing to
consider when you're paragliding above
like a lake or something your stamina is
running out when you're holding it it
takes energy to hold on to that when the
wind is pushing you every which way if
you fall in a lake it takes stamina to
swim you could easily drown so you can't
just aim for the middle of a lake to
negate falling damage right yeah but at
the same time maybe you can because I
found this item that is just like book
hobbling guts and I didn't think
anything of it other than oh yeah I'll
sell this or maybe I'll cook it but if
you read the description it says
something along the lines of like hmm
maybe you could use this to make
something float and so I was talking to
Spencer in the office about and he was
like oh like cuz I tied it to a weapon
in the weapon float and I was like okay
but I don't get the point of that and
then he was like oh maybe the weapon if
you have that attached to it you're
holding it will help you float and you
won't sink I'm just like wow I was I was
overhearing a conversation about that
and like it blew my mind like I'm never
gonna finish this game I feel like I
will always be playing it it's I think
you know something that's immediately
apparent is that you just have you don't
feel like you understand like there's so
many games go out of their way to meet
like are you sure you got everything
yeah understands it all you specifically
like Zelda games some do Skyward Sword
eat it how it did that coming off of
Skyward Sword this is such a don't want
to say breath of fresh air every yes
it's it's it's crazy helm by the same
director to which which kind of blows my
mind yeah and obviously like the fact
that there's so much detail in this game
and so many interlocking systems
probably a testament to the fact that
it's the biggest team Nintendo's ever
had in a project right yes and it's and
it also has incorporated monolith soft
who made Xenoblade Chronicles and the
world is super evident of their and
their involvement it's great verticality
and you know even something as simple as
like you know a large plane will look
interesting even though just a huge
field of grass they manage to change the
elevation just the right ways and
there's been a lot of time and energy
put into even what seems like the most
basic elements of this game and I think
that's only possible when you
do something like a company Nintendo
making the biggest game they've ever
made and that's the thing about it it's
it's constantly reminding you not in a
bad way that yeah it's a Zelda game but
I'm not thinking through it like I
usually Rosella game usually a Zelda
game I'm kinda the open world is just
there for to get to me to the next
dungeon or to get the next Megaton
hammer or the fairy bow or the hook shot
in this I'm constantly thinking I'm
thinking do I have enough like pepper
soup or whatever it is to make keep me
warm when I'm going into the mountains
or else I'm gonna freeze to death and
you I have four hearts I'm gonna be
[ __ ] if I don't yeah that's what I was
gonna ask as we started this
conversation talking about like is it
more like are we excited because it does
elde the game or because it's doing all
these interesting things and that's the
it's very different from how I would
normally approach Zelda like I I thought
I had the language of Zelda down and
then playing this it's like oh I have to
completely learn a new yeah vocabulary
to be able to play this game yeah you
know the first five hours there are
these shrines you go into and though
these tutorial I mean they are kind of
tutorials for how you use the sheikah
slate for the powers it's like it's just
a splash screen right it's just a little
thing this has press this button to
activate this power can you figure it
out and in the dungeon yeah you figure
yeah but but but even it's a good
tutorial but it's not because those
dungeons are really shrines like they
grow in complexity over time so yeah
they start basic but it's certainly not
like anywhere near what sky hurts or
just I wanna keep talking - can forever
we could talk much more about it next
week when your review is out that you'll
be up tomorrow yes I'll be doing a
livestream tomorrow 8 a.m. 8 - left
three hours right yeah we're just gonna
Pacific time we're just gonna talk about
all the things I can't talk about today
has a [ __ ] ton of questions I want to
get to because I would be remiss if I
did not
don't be remiss Mike you mentioned
degradable weapons Andrew jelly on
Twitter says do the degradable weapons
in breath the wild dampen the experience
they're not as fond of those types of
mechanics and games how do you feel
about that mm-hmm
it certainly feels strange at first
because Elda games you sort of always
measure your progress by what gear and
equipment you have right so to lose a
weapon that seems cool it's kind of like
oh that's a bit of a bummer
but you have an endless supply of
weapons and because they they evolve
over time like in terms of where you are
in the world what's available in a
particular environment
you get to use like a lot of different
stuff it's not just like four swords
I know it's title of a Zelda game you
know what I mean like it's not just
having a handful of swords you are
dealing with I mean I have no idea how
many variations of weapons so yes the
things break but it's super fascinating
to me just that it doesn't actually
impede on the experience because link is
struggling to do everything right and
you could argue that like well maybe
weapons don't need to break for him to
still struggle but like it's just that
extra little notch I'm just dialing it
up and making it you making you have to
consider a little bit more but you're
never out of weapons right you have the
bomb thing that you can use if you find
an enemy that has something when you
don't have any weapons throw a bomb on
him yeah they're not they're not a
limited quantity we're limited in that
it's based on an ax yeah yeah yeah
there's no no real mana to speak of
though right it's cool it's cool yeah
sure
and yeah I felt I found that the
degradable weapons was constantly
changing my approach each time like I
have this bow cobbling Club I can you go
so I'm like oh I'm set
but then that breaks the next camp like
I'm out - I have a twig maybe I could
just smack them with it or I could go up
to his fire light it and throw it at
them to blow out these barrels next to
them which I might not have done if I
was just gonna go in with that bow
cobbling Club yeah I mean you're forced
to just sort of try things differently
all the time but that's a great that's a
great thing yeah I I think the
degradable weapons work I would not have
thought I would have said that and when
is zelda game but i normally don't like
that
i'ma can't because I'm just it's always
like it seems tedious but it works very
well yeah because you're constantly
managing your inventory sources and and
that's a big part of what you're doing
and so it it goes very well with what's
already there versus some games I'm like
okay I really like my sword broke really
okay yes I'm gonna go do this thing
that's if the rest of the game is linear
or something it seems very unnatural and
this is very different right cd14 on
Twitter was asking of all the 3d Zelda's
which one is breath of the wild from the
first five hours that we played most
reminiscent of I didn't play a lot of
Twilight Princess cuz I couldn't get
past that wolf tutorial in terms of I
just didn't want to play it yeah
you know I got a really strong vibe
similar to the way I felt when I played
ocarina of time maybe not because of the
mechanical similarities or the systems
at play but it just that sense of just
like this is new like this is new and
exciting and you know it's it feels like
zelda but it's doing things i've never
really done in a Zelda game before like
for Ocarina of Time that was just being
in 3d you know to a point but here it's
so much more but it said I get that same
sense of just amazement it definitely
recaptures that feeling like I remember
playing Ocarina of Time and you see
Death Mountain in the distance and you
like realizing you can go there was such
a big deal and obviously now it's you
know you doesn't have replaying it
doesn't have that same feel because we
you know you can go there but that scene
we saw earlier where you're looking out
and there's like a mountain in the
distance it's like that feeling of
Ocarina of Time times a thousand yeah
and I love that it's giving me that
sense again of I don't even know where I
am I'm gonna go yet but I'm gonna go
over there I'm gonna figure it out maybe
it's just me but I feel like this all
the series is kind of been just like
spinning its tires for a while I mean
like they introduced these new mechanics
like I think link between worlds was
fantastic yeah sure right but but but
not something that is like revolutionary
sure right the way that this seems to be
like it's it's I mean that game mean
quite heavily into the fact that like
hey it's the old system but we've
tweaked it a little bit right you know
what I mean this is just kind of like
nothing old is here it this is all new
this is very different based on the
first five hours is almost like Nintendo
didn't want to say what makes his LD
game and how can we iterate on that it
seems like they ask themselves how do we
change the definition of a Zelda you
know yeah
and that's super exciting and I wish we
could talk way more about that but um
more specifically is aiming in breadth
of the wild on either platform of
someone J Chi and the twitch chat was
asking this is coming to Wii U they
asked yes it is do we know one specific
date watch that cool we have not tried
that version yeah we have not tried it
but yes GG the twitch is coming to Wii U
but someone asks
on either platform is aiming on breath
of the wild exclusively reliant on the
gyroscopic gyroscopic functionality can
you disable it you can say but yeah you
can choose to use it or not I actually
like to use it on switch especially when
I'm playing in handheld mode and with
the pro controller it helps to there are
times like when precision is necessary
where like you're manipulating something
using like a magical power where it's
like I get a weird angle and it's like
alright I'm now twisting my switch like
this I should just yeah use the analog
stick yeah when I was using the joique
on the frame controller with the joy
cons on it I was aiming with this analog
stick but then when I switched to the
changed to the handheld tablet I was
using the gyroscope and I love that it
feels really yes yeah bunch of questions
about this so what are the consequences
of death and Zelda I think a lot of
people are wondering is there like a
Dark Souls esque
thing or is it just a game over and
restart it's just a game over and you
restart from one of the last of many
auto saves the game does a good job of
realizing like when you're entering an
area that might be threatening and
saving the game for you and you can also
just do in like an old scale old-school
Zelda pause and save yes and you're
allowed once one slot for manual saves
okay so you can't it's not like Skyrim
where you can have a [ __ ] ton saved up
no yeah so you just be like I messed up
I'm gonna start from this save right so
I move which that I like that though it
if I had a ton I would maybe go back
like 10 saves and then restart these
outposts you're back in the system right
then you're not really part not
surviving the adventure the way it's
meant to be yeah with one change you
have to rely on just the items you have
or this that you did in your last save
and I like that yeah I like that too but
then and then like just a lot of
questions in general that last question
the consequence of death was George M on
Twitter but yeah in general it's almost
it just feels like a simulation game
almost and like how these mechanics can
like a SimCity or anything about how
these mechanics can interlock and how
these systems are kind of layered on top
of each other yeah there's a pretty good
physics model at play I've only played
five hours earn I played like four hours
and we can only talk about the first
five hours but so far I feel like I'm
thinking constantly more than I do in
open-world games I love horizon
I've been playing a lot of that but even
then I'm still kind of going through the
motions to get from point A to point B
if I'm not hunting an animal even when I
come across certain machines and I've
fought before I'm going through the
motions I have this muscle memory and I
turn my brain off just play Zelda I'm
constantly thinking so far yeah and
that's weird
for a Zelda game I mean you know you go
into dungeons and you puzzles and you're
thinking constantly right and like you
know the water temple or the Fire Temple
or snow-peak ruins but now I'm thinking
like I'm halfway up this cliff my
stamina is half drained
it is cold so I need to somehow get to a
place where I can eat this soup I cooked
earlier that will warm me up and resist
the cold but I might fall off this cliff
before I get up there so now I'm
battling I'm balancing stamina and my
cold like hypothermia I can get which is
gonna deplete my health I'm [ __ ] if I
can't get up to the top of this cliff in
the next 10 seconds really it's
constantly like you're weighing like
opportunity cost of things and and
weighing like okay here's what I have
here's what I can cook here's what I can
do if I don't fall off this cliff which
I might yeah it's you know some people
are saying it looks like it's more of an
open world survival game with a Zelda
finish but to circle back for the end of
the segment to the question I was asking
before it does it feel like a Zelda game
it does to me
Kellie what about you yeah yeah I would
say so yeah there are story points early
in the game that we won't spoil that I
think sets up a very Zelda like story
yes yeah and there's little touches as
well that are very familiar yeah I think
like people feel at home despite all
that's new and strange around them
puzzle solving there are dungeons maybe
down the traditional sense of you're
gonna go to this one
get this medallion then you're gonna
have to go to going up Mount def
mountain told countless times you don't
even need to go through the dungeons
right yeah you can yeah you can once you
get off the first area you can try to go
right to Ganon I mean even when it's not
crazy right even when it's not similar
to what we know about Zelda in terms of
gameplay or structure it still to me has
like the the spirit and feel of Zelda I
think Nintendo generally does this
really well is giving like a certain
kind of charm and
characterization with very minimal like
without using words Nintendo is really
good at that and so in that sense I I
feel even in the beginning a lot more of
Zelda in that sense rather than in
structure I'm just reading this I don't
know if we have a new story up but
apparently the prototype for breath of
the while back of the day started as an
8-bit game at a GDC talked just now
breath the wild director I might be
butchering this he tomorrow fujibayashi
yeah reveal a prototype of the game that
looks remarkably like the original 8-bit
rendition of Legend of Zelda both with
concepts and introduced and breath of
the wild it was used as a proof of proof
concept okay no I can see that that
makes sense okay and that was a the
verge just published that story I just
saw in my Twitter feed that's cool
because I think this game is actually
kind of hewing closely to what made the
original legends that look great at that
time in 1987 it certainly just like lets
you loose right with like yeah here you
are you don't have yeah this sword yeah
which is cool um you mean the Hermit he
gives you a thing yes good luck
talk to an old man yeah a hint we would
love to keep talking about this game we
could talk about it much more after
Pete's review goes up tomorrow morning 3
a.m. Pacific time yes and check for the
video review on site and on YouTube and
all that and then at 8 a.m. to 11 a.m.
Pacific Pete and Rob handler will be
playing straight through 3 hours of it
just until they drop and everything is
fair game all restrictions are office if
you want to talk about whatever yeah
we're kind of holding ourselves back now
especially Pete because he's played so
much of it but tomorrow he will not have
to so the review will be up I'm sorry if
I don't get some more questions I wish
we had more time keep sending them to
Pete I bother him aside Pete but yeah
thank you for everybody who send them
via Twitter and via twitch and YouTube
chats I appreciate it and let us know
you think if you're watching this on
GameSpot after the fact or YouTube we
appreciate the comments
[Music]